how good is your laundry
I'm sorry to say that no one's that good
just as a fan watching it it's a
visceral loving it it's a visceral like
wanting more Lance Reddick has died the
actor known for roles on the wire and in
the John Wick franchise was 60 years old
a rep for the actor tells E.T he died
from natural causes law enforcement says
officers responded to an emergency call
from reddick's home Friday morning no I
don't care how you do it
but I need my wire today Reddick has
been a familiar face across TV and
movies for over two decades so you think
it's good for business to put it out on
the street that our Witnesses get killed
fans of the wire know him best from his
breakout role on the acclaimed HBO
series you surprised me Mr Bishop well I
mean the fans that we have a kind of
rabbit Reddick later joined the cast of
Fringe followed by the TV adaptation of
Michael Connelly's crime novel series
Bosch
that serious demeanor and commanding
voice Redick often turned into comedy I
don't want to see another human being's
foot for the rest of the day but it was
on the big screen series
Reddick found his biggest audience as a
staple in the John Wick universe
gazillion people are going to see it and
gazillion people are going to keep
singing in et's final interview with
Reddick just two weeks prior to his
death he was promoting the latest
installment in the film franchise and
confirmed he had already filmed his part
for the John Wick spin-off ballerina
what makes Ana de armas like the perfect
person she's a she's a actor and second
of all you've already seen her action
shops in James Bond after three films
that got bigger and bigger bigger and
the fan fandom got bigger and bigger
bigger I mean what else are they gonna
do before his death Reddick filmed a
major role in the upcoming remake of
White Men Can't Jump and he was set to
play Zeus in the Percy Jackson TV series
for Disney plus Reddick is survived by
his wife and two children
thank you
[Music]